الله محمد ى الله عليه
وسلم
kindness
the
sister
‏me the propet pe and bls upon
them it means his
wies
daughter
an their children and those that beli in
and الله سبحانه
وتال
tells محمد ى الله عليه ولم comm
na
and and honor the mers of his
household and his
reles this
is
‏and
according
islamic
خمام الحسين ابن علي عليه السلام may
الله
ى الله عليه
وسلم
and for الامام
الحسين
الله
محم
us
the in our isic
his الح علي رضي
عنه
كبلا this
nation for more than days we
would
عاشوراء ام عطيه رضي الله
[Silence]
عنها
الامام
الحسين الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الحين we need to be cons from our
sadness with
j
understanding الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ي
عن
those this
great
tribulation there are
situations and
position that
do ‏may never
about none of us can
say what we would have said or done dur
that
time
so it is wise to spare our from
this الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله سبحانه
وتالى a nation that
passed they will have they will what
they
deser and you will have what you deserve
you will not be responsible
for
الامام
الحسين رضي الله
عنه
iny م صل الله عليه
وسلم
h
complete الامام الحسين
صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتالى
[Silence]
الله
الامام الحسين رضي الله
عنه
مدين
هجره صلى الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
per
par
الحسين
مجد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
whoever to leer of the you parad should
look him رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الحسين
‏me صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله
lin احب الله من احب
حسنا س
الامام
الحسين
2ه
هج
[Silence]
خوارج
مجره رضي الله تعالى
عن
كوف الامام الحسن رضي الله عنه
وارضاه خليفه
معاويه الامام
الحسين
[Silence]
الحسن رضي الله تعالى
عنهما
الامام
الحسين
معاويه
معاو
م ان شاء الله
تالى next frid i will continue that
ision of امام
الحسين رضي الله عنه او
الله the grand messenger الله عليه وسلم
and the
اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين واعلي كلمه الحق والدين اللهم
ارنا الحق حقا وفقنا اتباعه وارنا الباطل
باطلا وفقنا اجتنابه اللهم وفقنا لعمل
بكتابك وسنه نبيك محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
واجعلنا على منهج الخلفاء الراشدين ومنهج
اهل واهل بيت اهل بيت رسول الله الطاهرين
ومنهج الصحابه الكرام رضوان الله تعالى
عليهم اجمعين اللهم اغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما
اخرنا وما اسررنا وما اعلنا وما انت اعلم
به منا اللهم اغفر لنا وارحمنا وتب علينا
وسامحنا واختم يا ربنا بالصالحات اعمالنا
واخر د ان الحمد لله رب العالمين ان الله
يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى
وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم
لعلكم
تذكرون واقم الصلاه يرحمك الله